I'm so out of it I have no idea what I'm
saying right now how do you celebrate
tonight how do you celebrate I'm gonna
go dancing yeah with the kids from her
boyfriend Tom Cullen the three-time
Canadian Screen Award winner Critics
Choice winner Golden Globe nominee and
now Emmy winner danced her way on stage
overwhelmed by the moment but maybe not
as much as Keith Sutherland who did the
unthinkable and pulled the John Travolta
messing up her name just moments before
- John yamasa you - John yamasa you
luckily she didn't even notice my tongue
my family thank you so much I I feel so
lucky to be on a show that puts women at
the center and thank you so much to the
Academy the response after the first
season was so much positivity in terms
of representation and the way that young
girls were seeing themselves portrayed
on screen and the LGBT community as well
really reached out and supported us
before all the press tatianna Prix
snacks with Tom who was by her side for
every historic moment she is the first
Canadian woman to win upstanding leading
actress in a Drama Series and Tom summed
her up perfectly instagramming this
photo with the caption Slayer is that
the good luck dress now forever the good
luck never gonna wash it after being
nominated last year as a girl with 12
split personality speed out Viola Davis
taraji P Henson Keri Russell Robin
Wright and Claire Danes something her
co-stars and fans were hoping for using
a certain hashtag which trended all
night long
create a hashtag of tonight what would
the hashtag be any forum is Lonnie
trending it's happening yeah